il est midi et le sel de ce collège du
gers est désertée l'établissement a
rouvert ses portes récemment et doit
s'adapter aux nouvelles directives pour
sa rentrée post confinement c'est
désormais dans leur salle de classe que
les élèves prennent leur repas sains par
table est toujours en respectant les
distances de sécurité
c'est un déjeuner en silence presque
studieux chacun groupe à sa classe avec
sa table et c'est il ya un marquage sur
chaque espace et chaque classe dont
qu'ils avaient déclassifié avec un
espace de cours dédiés et il n'y a aucun
croisement entre les élèves et les
groupes d'élèves et une autre classe de
ce côté-ci sur ce bâtiment avec une cour
de l'autre côté où chaque classe a son
espace à réserver en temps normal ce
collège accueille 300 élèves dont 70
pensionnaires
désormais c'est une quarantaine
d'adolescents qui occupent les lieux
les effectifs des classes ont été
divisées de moitié une table vide ses
parts dès à présent chaque élève de son
voisin une ambiance pesante règne dans
la salle de classe
il est très difficile pour eux de garder
leur masse toute la journée en classe
c'est carrément une torture on est sans
arrêt en train de regarder
ils ont du mal à parler ils ont du mal à
respirer on voit bien que ça l'est ça
les fatigue face est évident et pour
leur permettre de souffler même à
travers leurs masques le collège a mis
en place des cours de sport quotidien
afin que les élèves puissent se dépenser
physiquement en toute sécurité
la rentrée des élèves de 6e et 5e des
établissements situés en zone verte
s'est effectuée en toute sérénité ce
lundi en ce qui concerne les collégiens
de 4e et de 3e ainsi que les lycéens
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
devrait se prononcer à la fin du mois de
mai